hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new 2020 imac
5k that we've been waiting for a long
time
and before we open it i almost forgot i
still have my mask on
this thing is super comfortable way more
comfortable than my other masks
no exaggeration so if you guys want to
stay safe and support mac stick at the
same time
go and check it out along with our other
merch down below in the merch shelf
let's go ahead and get this thing opened
up now in this video we're not only
going to take a look at the thermal
performance and fan noise
and compare it to the previous model but
we're also going to compare the
performance to a version that cost
850 dollars more last year and missed
some of the features
now before we do that let me show you
how easy it is to upgrade the ram that's
the first thing i want to do because i
saved 760 dollars ordering 64 gigs of
ram
myself instead of buying it from apple
it only cost me
240 bucks instead of a thousand that is
absolutely crazy
don't let apple rip you off now i'll
just line up the ram like that
pop one in the next one
the third one and then the last one
there we go that was how easy it is to
upgrade
took me just a minute no it doesn't void
your warranty you could save up to 2
100 for 128 gigabytes of ram
we have links down below and we have
links to our three-minute ram and slal
guide if you want more details
and as you guys could see we have 64
gigs of ram running at the crack speed
everything is working properly now the
imac that we have here is the 8 core
model that is standard for the 2300 spec
with the 5500 xt and all in
with the ram we're looking at about 2
500 and we're gonna compare it to what
would have cost us last year for a model
with eight cores and the better graphics
at about 3500
and then the previous base so we do have
the higher end 10 core coming in with
the best graphics card but apple's only
shipping those
end of next week so make sure you guys
are subscribed if you want to see info
on that one and how these two will
compare
let's jump into our tests we're going to
start off with geekbench
5 i'm going to do the cpu test here and
we're using intel power gadget to view
the frequencies
that just hit 5.1 gigahertz right there
5.1 did you guys see that now it's at
5.0 so this
processor is eight core right there 5.1
again i don't know why
the wind is 5.0 it says it's supposed to
go to 5.0 it's doing single core tasks
right now
it's supposed to go up to 5 gigahertz
just like last year
if you spent the extra 400 bucks to get
an 8 core processor now
it is standard instead of being a 6 core
so it does hit the advertised frequency
intel power gadget is showing actually
5.1 for some reason that's weird
that's a positive and now this eight
core that's included
it the base clock is actually 3.8
gigahertz compared to the previous ones
3.6 so that is also interesting along
with that last year if you paid 400
for the acor upgrade the highest we saw
that hit
was 4.8 gigahertz not 5.0
or in this case 5.1 and as far as
wattage we just hit
129 now 117. this is the multi-core test
starting
um 129 watts so it is actually peaking
higher than last year
i think was 117 last year 115 was the
highest it went last year so it has
access to a little bit more power if it
needs it
and here's our results the single core
is a little bit faster than the best
processor last year
which actually was the best single core
performing mac out of all of the macs
and as far as the multi-core we're just
over seven percent faster
this year and this acor is included
compared to paying
four hundred dollars more for the i-98
core last year so that's definitely a
good improvement
we'll still have to see how good the 10
core does and we'll test it out as soon
as we get it and as far as graphics goes
i ran
the metal test in geekbench 5 and we got
a result of
42 000 which is about the same as the
previous 580x
which came on this specification they
both have eight gigabytes of video
memory
this memory is a little bit faster now
you have to keep an eye this doesn't
tell the whole story we are going to
have a review
with a lot of real world tests because
there are certain things have been
greatly upgraded
such as the video encoders they are
three to four times faster
in this new navi graphics chip h.265
decoding there's a lot that is going on
there because
the 580x that architecture is from 2016
so that's
much much older of course if you want a
lot more raw graphics performance you
can spend the extra on the 5700 xt
which we recommend for a lot of people
it's a lot more powerful
now let's take a look at gaming
performance so i'm testing using unigine
heaven and i'm using the extreme
preset and so far it looks to be running
fairly well
and our temperatures for the graphics
it's at 66 degrees celsius fairly cool
but we'll see what we get under the test
so it looks like we have a score of 64.2
frames per second our graphics ship
stayed at about 82
83 degrees celsius and the fans stayed
at their lowest speeds
of basically 1200 rpm we got 11.98
that is about 40 faster than that 580x
that was the base spec previously so
even though in the metal test it was
very similar
like i said there's a lot of
architecture updates and 40
faster for gaming and not only that but
it's just
four frames per second shy than the vega
48
which cost 450 dollars to
upgrade to so right there for gaming and
for cpu
our cpu is faster gaming performance is
almost as fast while saving 850 dollars
and now let's push this imac to its
limits with cinebench r20 we're gonna
max out
all eight of those cores take a look at
our fan speeds our temperatures
our frequencies all of that stuff let's
go ahead and hit
run i'm going to watch the how much
wattage it
ends up using here so bam we got a nice
spike 153
oh geez okay well that's gonna cause it
to heat up quickly but it's still doing
okay
156 okay i guess apple's being a lot
less conservative
last time the highest it spiked was 120
and it's still staying at 159 there
temps
are going up frequencies at 4.7 this
whole time
that's under 8 cores of load so i don't
know if they've just done a lot of
optimizations
or what 98 degrees right here the fans
are spitting up but it's
apple is pushing this thing hard we're
almost done here i'm going to run this
test again because i wanted this thing
to heat up
48 46 was our score the first time let's
run that sucker again
so we're almost done with the second run
here it's running at 4.4 gigahertz
and the first run was 20 faster than
last year's i9 so we went down
46 98 went down a little bit more let's
keep pushing this thing
so it looks like it's running
consistently at about 4.4 gigahertz
instead of last year it ran at about 3.7
to 3.8 so the frequency is staying
much higher and 46.70 we got on the
third run
it is running a little bit hotter a
little bit louder because they're
pushing it harder but the performance
difference
is definitely noticeable and this year
the eight core standard you don't have
to pay an extra
four hundred dollars for that one and
then of course comparing this to the
previous six core
that's a massive difference in
performance so what did we learn
in our thermal and benchmark video well
as far as the actual cpu performance
i'm really pleasantly surprised
not only is this actual new 8 core which
is standard
about 20 faster slightly higher than 20
percent
than the i9 that you had to pay 400 for
comparing the base spec it used to come
with the six core for the same price
that is almost twice as fast as far as
the cpu performance
and as far as the graphics we have much
much newer graphics finally an
update to the ones that they stuck with
for a long time
and for a gaming performance that had a
40 improvement
and along with that the fans stay
totally silent when we're doing
a gaming test so overall for the same
money
you're getting a killer deal and now
for most people you can save probably
about a thousand dollars compared to
last year
and get similar or even better
performance so that's definitely a win
in our book
now we are going to compare this 2300
model to the one that's a 10 core
with the 5700 xt and then do our full
review as well with real world tests
along with video editing photo editing
things like that so make sure you guys
are subscribed
once again you guys can check out our
merch down in the merch shelf below
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video